britney spears and sam askari are
officially married this is just a
groundbreaking day and the couple is
dancing till the world ends
a source confirms to et that the couple
tied the knot at the pop star's home in
thousand oaks california she's doing
great i'm great i'm just it's the
happiest time of our lives and we're
just enjoying it i'm really blessed
ahead of the nuptials we're told that
they were quote so excited they have
felt like true partners for a long time
i won the biggest wedding in the world
it's up to her she's wearing the pants
now she's wearing the pants all right
turns out sam didn't get a big wedding
britney opted for a small intimate
ceremony yeah the guest list was very
exclusive some major names that didn't
make the list some of britt's family
mom lin dad jamie and sister jamie lynn
all did not get invites
but that's no surprise because our
source tells us quote inviting them was
never a question et's also learned
brittany's sons whom she shares with
kevin fetterline sean preston and jaden
james didn't attend their mom's wedding
their dad's powerhouse attorney tells et
that although they didn't make it to the
celebration quote kevin and the boys are
happy for brittany and wish her and sam
all the best going forward they are
excited that this will be a positive
development for her post-conservatorship
from here on it's it's amazing it's
heaven from here on out what's going to
be next well you know you already know
everyone knows already sooner or later
sooner or later what a wedding when do
you want it to be sooner or later yeah
you might remember back in may sam
teased us save the date for the wedding
on his insta stories he wrote the big
day has been set but nobody will know
until the day after
hmm well we might have cracked the code
a bit early so this is my second time to
ever be in a rose voice the night before
they said their i do's brittany and sam
kicked off their wedding weekend
arriving in style while enjoying
champagne in a rolls-royce i'm really
excited there's stores on the ceiling
and there's also
very very tiny champagne glasses which
i've never had that are very cold
already with champagne and i feel very
um sophisticated with all
on my and
my nails see i'm really excited about
that
brittany and sam first met on the set of
her 2016 music video for slumber party
[Music]
fast forward to september 2021 they
announced their engagement
sam stood by brittany as she battled to
the end of her 13-year conservatorship
which officially ended in november
e.t caught up with sam in march where he
gave an update on brittany's regained
freedom everything's amazing we're so
excited to start a new chapter and
everything's so positive from here on
out
[Music]
you